do you think like this opens up a
conversation about who these people are
cuz that is what I'd really like to see
happen yeah and I don't think it will
now I don't think it will I think we'll
move past it
yeah because it's a I don't know I just
I feel like people are it's too heavy
it's like too much it's too much dude do
you think there will be any kids that
like we find out like 10 11 like kid
kids
yeah even likes it gonna be bad when
that comes out that's gonna get [ __ ]
really really scary and here if you're
just not you're okay with the 13 fair
enough no what I you know when Russ
Baker wrote that book family of secrets
and and I read it and he described the
process of writing it and he said to me
and Raycom the great writ Kampf he said
when I started to really understand who
these people are and how they operated
the book and the process of writing it
had the profundity of theology meaning
it was so profound it was a religious
experience I started to understand
things that I net that never made any
sense to me that started to make sense
all of these questions that I had about
why things operated a certain way they
started to become more clear as I
understood who these people were
and also as I understood all the
influences and the pressures that were
exerted on them how some of them had
been blackmailed
some of them owed their political career
to you know a certain billionaire a
certain power broker that these people
had been party to criminal acts that
were then covered up and the people that
facilitated that cover-up were able to
use that and leverage power and pull
strings and he goes once you start
seeing how all of that happens it's it's
clear to you that that dumb remember
School of Rock it's like how a bill
becomes a law
- bill sitting here on Capitol Hill and
you read that I mean you watch that I
mean like oh that's what happens the
house legislation originates there goes
to the Senate then it goes to the
president that's not really it that's a
very positive way of looking at how
things get done you know have you seen
that I'm just a bill yeah yeah back and
everybody has seen that mm-hmm that's
not what it is no it's not what it is
it's like I'm just do bill I was
sponsored by a senator he [ __ ] a kid
in a hotel in Washington there was a
camera there and someone sent that photo
to him and now he said we need a war
we're gonna have a war and they said
you're gonna have three more wars he
said okay don't tell them I [ __ ] the
kid and I'm just a bill I was written
with blood I'm just a bill I was written
with blood I go to the house then the
Senate floor there were cameras at that
party they saw you for that hall and I'm
just a bill and I think that's what it
really is we killed the Kennedy we put
Mike Michael Hastings went through a
tree I'm just a bill don't look at me
I'm just a bill we had a debate
it wasn't about rape that's the chopped
and screwed versions the chopped and
screwed version you know that's great
that's what it really is yeah it's not
[ __ ] people having you know well I
think you know who I really want to be
on this plane Acacio Cortez
I want to cost you a Cortes to come out
and go yeah I [ __ ] those old white
[ __ ] I [ __ ] them and I don't feel
bad about it
I [ __ ] them and I stole their wallets
and I took that cash they gave it to the
poor the Bronx I want to have him a
moment with her like how she does lose
like three to five minute clip yeah
where she just gets out and you know the
phones are on her and she's like we're
about to go viral [ __ ] mm-hmm
like yeah I [ __ ] up see he's they said
he has a weird little deck like an
egg-shaped penis a tiny egg-shaped penis
oh and I want her to be like I put that
old egg in my [ __ ] mouth I knew
exactly what I was doing that
billionaire [ __ ] I went in there I
[ __ ] them all alan dershowitz ate my
ass and you know as he was eating my ass
you know what I was doing I was reading
Marx and get him ready for the war
I used my sexuality as a weapon against
those old [ __ ] i infiltrated that
Island that's great it would be great it
would be powerful